thank you
we are here at the Panthers ice Den in
Coral Springs Florida we are here in
Florida it is warm and humid Sunny Coral
Springs Florida and spending most of it
in a freezing ice rink and I wouldn't
have it any other way welcome to the
2022 um
hockey is just
just an amazing game I love the contact
it's a stress reliever it's definitely a
special game battle for it in the
neutral zone balancing on some blades
stick handling and scoring and trying to
make sure you don't get check these in
the boards I love the heighteness of the
game being in Florida is just an icing
on the cake we are at the Amerigo latam
Cup this will be the fourth Amerigo
latam cup all minorities want to be a
part of it it's had a explosive growth
from the inaugural event in 2018. now
we've gone from five teams originally to
44 teams this year
[Music]
this tournament is important for the
Nations that are participating because
hockey is still considered to look and
quite honestly sound one way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in my 28 years of being in the hockey
world this is the first time that I've
ever been fully immersed in a Latin
American ice hockey tournament there is
hockey in Latin America and they're very
passionate about the game the experience
has been amazing by far one of the best
tournaments that I've been a part of we
are a proud and passionate people
[Music]
hearing the music that I usually just
wear my headphones for because I don't
want the other people to hear it felt
amazing the energy is hype every game
it's such a cool experience to see
people who look like us playing hockey
together and the camaraderie around the
event it's it's unbelievable and it
makes everything the whole experience
very special
wouldn't you fall in love with the game
of hockey
when I could walk when did you fall in
love with hockey oh I fell in love with
hockey when I was 13. I fell in love
with hockey when I was five years old I
started when I was four I had an older
brother who played been playing since I
was eight I wasn't the best when I was a
kid but
I kept at it I started playing hockey at
13 years old I was born and raised in
the island soon as I came to the states
one of the first thing I've asked my dad
was when can we go hit the ice I
remember it was only one girl per team
and my dad didn't want me playing out
with the guy so he put me in net and he
thought that was safer
my parents they wanted to put me in
figure skating and I said absolutely not
I want to hit some boys like my brother
so I got into hockey and I've been
playing ever since
hockey's my escape from life being able
to get away from my personal life
problems or just having a bad day just
being on the ice just it's an amazing
feeling being able to play with people
who have the same love for the game
and try to get my breath I honestly just
go to the place of why why I'm here who
am I doing it for the one thing we want
to keep going is is the growth of this
organization and the nation and Puerto
Rico hockey within itself finding this
team has been something that I will
always be so grateful for being able to
be in a team that we all share the same
struggles but in so many different
stories it's really comforting to be the
best teammate I think about
representation and growing the game I
think about the young boys and girls
that are seeing us for the first time
and understanding that wow I can do that
all I want to do is give these players
of color and opportunity to play the
game that we all love love to see that
the stadium rink is full of supporters I
am very acutely aware there are those of
us who represent a more vast and diverse
community in hockey so I see this
tournament as a way of amplifying our
history and pushing our narrative into
the Forefront for the future of this
sport
[Applause]